without help feeding maisie ashton and
abby during lockdown would have been
impossible for mum tara she's been
getting daily food parcels
but sometimes even they don't go far
enough it's because it's got to be
rationed because you're living on
benefits that's a difficult thing
that's why as soon as the kids do go
back to school i can't wait to get into
work because benefit life is
it's good for a start off but you need
more in a family
the parcels are assembled this warehouse
in coventry it's a military-style
operation
to get food to the most vulnerable
pallets stacked with breakfast boxes
packed ready to feed families we've got
some cereals here
apples and satsumas demand from the
community
continues to rise you know we didn't
have anything like this
uh about two or three months ago and
this has been a covid19
response to a dramatic rise in food
poverty in the city of coventry
you know in the last 13 weeks the food
bank here
has seen almost doubling of demand an
independent report warns there are
likely to be
thousands more families like tara who
have been left in the lurch by the
pandemic
the national food strategy recommends
expanding holiday hunger schemes and for
free school meals to be given to all
children with parents
on universal credit all interventions
focused on tackling
child poverty the ceos of these firms
are not innocent
haplessly bobbing around on the ways of
commerce they can go into their
boardrooms tomorrow
and say let's stop this it comes after
footballer marcus rashford forced the
government into a colossal u-turn
on free school meal vouchers an issue
that continues to be close to his heart
this week he volunteered at a food bank
in london
the expansion of access to schemes like
this could aid
millions of children i think the fact
that 3.3
million new registrations for universal
credit show that families are really
struggling
and for many of them they absolutely
rely on that free school meal
um to make sure that their children get
at least one hot meal a day
and they're struggling to meet their
food bills
the government says they will carefully
consider the report's recommendations
so that for more families dinner time
doesn't have to be a burden
ash naharinag sky news